die dritte nicht scharf servus s kids
und herzlich willkommen aus österreich
wir sind in österreich in einem
sogenannten chalet so nennt sich dieses
gebracht diesen menschen hier mit max
also krankhafter und mit gesehen wir
drehen hier was richtig richtig geil ist
und schaut euch allein das thema an
leute die mir auf snapshot folgen haben
ein bisschen was mitbekommen das ist der
ausblick von unserem balkon hier ja die
anderen werden sich schon auf ihr
produzieren sondern so ein kleines
projekt wir haben hier drüben nachbarn
wir haben hier drüben nachbarn und
werden heute morgen mit einer drohne
gefilmt die schwebt ungefähr hier oben
und alle angeglotzt wie man ein guter
verwalter habe glotzt wie schweine es
geht mal rein stecken auch für die
anderen lasen sind
so sieht das aus da unten sind die
anderen beiden noch immer ist alles sehr
professionell ob es hier nun wirklich
spannend was dabei herauskommt wenn mich
jetzt auch noch mal ein spiel geht nicht
dass hier in unfairen vorteil bekommen
so wenn wir jetzt gerade schon ein game
aufgenommen wir sind alle schwer
verkabelt diesen dingen hier
peter habedank nicht gibt der
allergrößte liebe dich auch sagen über
sie sagen wir mal kurze pause dann geht
es weiter
die juso leute wir sind jetzt fertig mit
dem dreh für heute wären heute morgen um
9 uhr angefangen
um acht uhr gefrühstückt haben jetzt
haben wir 15 uhr programm vor das durch
matt ich auch fertig was geht was geht
wurst geht
hallo leute die haben etwas vorbereitet
in das haus gehe mir zu tun und zwar
werden wir eine kleine zielschießen
challenge machen wir haben nicht ein
paar nervt ganz zugeschickt bekommen und
wir werden folgendes machen und wir
stellen eine wasserflasche auf jeder
hatte was ich zeig euch zirkus wohl erst
mal barfuß im schnee
seht ihr das da unten den schneemann auf
den werden wir jetzt gleich die
wasserflasche draufstellen dann stellen
wir uns einem gewissen abstand von 345
metern oder so da vorne hin und dann hat
jeder einem magazin um die wasserflasche
vom schneemann runter zu schießen
und der verlierer des spiels muss in
boxer shorts und t shirt den schnee
springen würde richtig krass und ich
sollte vielleicht nur schnell raus geben
nicht auf und hob stehen okay leute die
regeln sind so weit klar ich will zeigen
wie zins jacken an
ich ziehe mir vielleicht noch socken und
schuhe an und dann geht's ab ich bin
gespannt aber wir haben die teile schon
ein bisschen länger und wir haben damit
letzter tag schon ein bisschen rum
gespielt und ich würde fast sagen dass
ich relativ gut schießen kann aber ja
ich bin schon bessere schütze
was wollen wir nehmen wir haben ja also
wir haben verschiedene wir haben einmal
die hier studiert so diese kleinen
bastler haben aber noch nicht die große
ich würde fast sagen wir nehmen die
mittleren die haben irgendwie bei 226
schuss 12 schuss 12 schuss hatte 12
schossen die tore zu schießen aber ich
hoffe dass ich am ende des tages nicht
im schnee denke ich
und nein es sehr erfreulich wird sagen
gelegen ist einfach los ohne groß zu
groß um zu reden und das paddel okay
leute ab nach draußen
so sind die dinge aus wir haben hier
zwei trommeln mit den dazu hier und hier
wir haben hier die flasche markiert blau
nein ist es schon immer gewesen und dann
werden ok bis bereit ich würde sagen
millimeter abstand machen ich fange an
wir markieren uns hier vorne ordentlich
von uns reagierten fleck so ist man
steht hier das sind 45 meter ja so eine
gute sache dann deine ersten und
einzigen zwölf versuche knapp
bisher schlosserei 34 schüssel und
vierten schuss trifft er direkt wer am
ende weniger getroffen user bahngehen
alles klar
ok verzogen und er trifft noch nicht
nummer eins ist klar so max schön hinter
die linie okay ich schwöre ich lebe
hatten ja und du etwas gemeiner
schnieber angriff und da oben also nicht
getroffen ob du hast so präzise ist man
weiß es nicht
weißt du was du für mich letzte schuss
so leute alle aller letzter schuss in
hassendorf schwimm bereit jetzt muss ich
echt gut zielen so leute meinen blaster
hat mir gute dienste erwiesen jetzt bist
du dran mit deinen hier genau was der
punkt und jetzt unten stabilisierende
lassen ist geladen und
knapp meinen kopf nicht
wir können jetzt schneller werden der
westen vergleich so leute es geht weiter
du stehst richtig eingeladen ist es
vorbei jawohl mag man da gibt es ja
schon auf einen dran noch im ersten
magazin aber bei mir war es ja am anfang
auch relativ stark stelle mir die
flasche wieder auf
und dann kommt zurück wurde geht es
weiter man muss wissen wer ein bisschen
tiefer glaube ich so ja vielleicht
extrem knapp leute wir wechseln die
kameraperspektive
aber auch die zielgenauigkeit mit einer
viel neues glück ich brauche noch ein
schuss gleich zu ziehen
ein treffer mein gott komm schon immer
ein bisschen gas ich habe einen was dass
die fliegen die ganze da drauf kommen
schon weiter so weiter so drei noch
kommt zwei stunden drauf noch zwei stück
noch zwei stück leute bitte trefft nicht
so riesig dass die fliegen ja ich sehe
ich lese ich war für jeden fall eines
loddar ein so gemein
der allerletzte schutzleute muss es kay
baden gehen und
naja leute so sehen sieger aus leute ich
würde sagen raus aus dem polier aus der
jacke und ab in den schnee hier vor
allen leuten oder wie er sagt auch jeder
freut sich ok dann bürger sei sie da
vorne sieht so richtig schön unberührt
aus weißt du okay so viel zu t shirt
dann würde das das problem erkannt
shirts trägt wobei wir erlauben dass du
dir die hose im gegenzug dafür dass du
kein t shirt dafür die hose hochkrempeln
das ist schon okay und richtig mit
anlauf 3 auf dem bauch oder auf dem
bauch 3
der coach hat 321 eingelöst schneemann
last oder den sieg kurz halten ich muss
sterben
gewusst also leute mit den nervt wenig
zielgenau mit den schnäbeln auch leute
wenn ihr bruder braucht ihr keine feinde
jetzt schon tot
ich habe mich jetzt wieder aufgewärmt es
war sehr kalt meine zehen funktionieren
aber wieder würdig das gefragt so dass
noch nicht alles denn cooler weise
dürfen wir auch noch ein paar nerds
blaster verlosen und zwar ein paar ist
untertrieben damit jede menge noch
besser die wir verlosen dürfen alle
infos dazu stehen unten in der
beschreibung und um an der verlosung
teilzunehmen bisher einfach nur einen
kommentar schreiben oder dieses video er
nichts besonderes rand schreiben wir
werden die zufällig auslösen und die
gewinnerin informieren so sind die
belastung aus der verlosen wir haben
zwei von den großen 24 von denen und
jede menge von den kleineren schreibt
unbedingt in die kommentare ob er die
signiert haben wollt dann schreiben wir
die euch mit schicken ihr euch raus wie
gesagt alle infos dazu in welchen
packages die verlost werden stehen in
der beschreibung gab es wird schon jetzt
witzig dann so den blaster zu haben
der dazu geführt hat dass es keinen
schnee springen musste ist habe ich ganz
heiß wie gesagt schon einfach kommentare
dieses video gaycken zwei einfach dass
man das video und dann nimm deine
verlosung teil
jetzt erst mal von hier